Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That
number is 2192. David P here is a voicemail
related to what we talked about yesterday
regarding Gavin Newsom. I said if Newsom
runs for president, they will go after him
for having been married to Donald Trump's or
married to Donald Trump's now wife, Kimberly.
GUILFOYLE Donald Trump, JR That is. And here's a
caller who says Democrats got to turn that around.
Speaker 2: Hi, David. This idea that GUILFOYLE
dated Newsom is bad for Newsom. Yeah, I think he's
a perfect example of what's wrong with messaging
from Democrats. Okay. It's bad for Trump. What
they could do is say GUILFOYLE is, you know, was
dating this flaming, you know, liberal that wants,
you know, all these liberal things. So therefore,
it's not a problem with gas. NEWSOM That he was
dating her. It's a problem with Trump. JR Is he
a real conservative? He's a real American. Is he
really someone for you? Or if he just as phony
that dates liberals when you're not looking?
Speaker 1: It's a perfectly fine analysis,
but Donald Trump, jr, at least for now,
isn't running for anything. And by the way,
it's not an attack that would work on a
republican candidate if donald trump jr
ran for something and then someone came out
of the woodwork and said, hey, you know what,
don jr. He's really a left winger. He's married
to this super left. Kimberly GUILFOYLE I think now
nobody believes Kimberly GUILFOYLE is left. Maybe
she was before, but she's clearly not now. She
spoke at CPAC. It will go it will get no traction.
That's the perfect example of something that will
go absolutely nowhere. So they will make it a
problem for Gavin Newsom should it be won? No,
probably not. It doesn't really make any sense.
But that's you're thinking logically and this is
an electorate on the American right wing that does
not think logically. We have a fantastic bonus
show for you today. California leaders wanted
inflation relief for poor seniors, and yet poor
seniors are being left out again. Where exactly?
We will talk about it on the bonus show. Secondly,
Idaho Republicans have rejected an amendment
allowing an abortion when it is necessary to
save a woman's life. So you have a split on these
serious but relatively rare situations. You have
some anti-choice advocates saying when it is
necessary for the life of the mother, it's not
actually an abortion. Like it might look like the
same procedure, it might have the same name, A,
T and C DNC, but it is a different procedure. So
there's the one side is playing the semantic game,
the other side is fighting the amendments to allow
for the exceptions. And we will talk about that on
today's bonus show. And lastly, the Department of
Justice has decided it will not prosecute a group
linked to Stephen Colbert's Late Show after some
unlawful entry arrests related to the Trump riots.
Why are those arrests not happening? Why
prosecutions, rather? I'm sorry. And also,
what case are the right wingers making that this
is a politically motivated decision? We will have
all of it on today's bonus show. How do you get
access to the bonus show? Very easy. You go to
join Pacman dot com and you sign up. That's it.
You can use the coupon code. Obama, not Obama.
That's with an end to get a discount off of the
cost of a membership. And you will get instant
access to the bonus show, instant access to the
commercial free audio video streams and priority
access to David Pakman show viewer town halls, the
next of which is on Tuesday, one week from today,
Tuesday, July. What is that? 20 6:06 p.m. Eastern.
We will be doing the next live town hall. We will
be streaming it only on the Pacman Live YouTube
channel. This is the other YouTube channel,
YouTube.com slash Pacman Live. You can watch only
if you prefer, but everybody is welcome to call in
and our members on the website will get
priority access, all of it. When you sign
up at join pacman dot com. We will see you on
the bonus show or otherwise back here tomorrow.